the past year has been um awful
um and i think all we've been focusing
on all i've been focusing on is the fact
that he's not here
um but coming up to the end of the trial
it was clear that you know something
needed to change here and
you know the least i feel like the least
we could do is offer
uh protectors some protection did andrew
always want to become a police officer
you know anyone who knew him
you could see that that was suited to
him he was always very
protective and kind
proactive and he always wanted to help
people
he's always had a very strong sense of
right and wrong
and i think you know all of his friends
we all
knew that he was so suited to that role
i mean i was just so proud of the way
that he
he did his job and he was just so
dedicated to it
widowhood is an excruciating
journey but what i don't want to do is
spend each day just
you know sitting trying to to get
through it i want to make
a change and i want to do something like
you say that
he would be proud of the pain will
always be there for me
the journey will always be hard
but i do constantly feel lucky to have
had
the relationship that we did um you know
it's a long time even for
for any relationship let alone one that
was
stolen so um abruptly
so it's hard but you know he he keeps me
going
um and he keeps me focused on what's
important and
you know that's why we're doing harper's
law i think
so long are there are there happy times
that you can still dwell on now when you
you know you remember your life together
many many happy times yeah
um you know we were together for over 12
years
um so that's a huge chunk of our
lives that we were side by side
you know every memory i have is it you
know
attached to him in some way so
you know i'm just glad we took so many
pictures
and then of course the terrible events
just just four weeks later
yeah i mean i know you don't want to go
into the detail of that night it's
it's too awful it's too awful to read
isn't it it's just
just horrendous yeah very unexpected
um but i think that's you know i've
learned
awful lot this past year about well
grief and um strength and
trying to be brave and that you know
brings me
you know to why i'm doing this now and
it's you know
a determination to make something
else out of this horrific year um
and instead of you know andrew's legacy
being about
the horrible way that he died maybe we
can
do something you know make a positive
change that i know that he would
be proud of you called his death
barbaric
um so how shocked were you then at the
verdict that the
the three young men were found not
guilty of murder
my husband has been taken um and
the people responsible will not be
paying for that
do you miss him yes all the time
yeah all the time what do you think he
would have made of you
out there campaigning like this he would
have been proud of me
um you know ultimately i'm i'm doing
this for him
um so it's you know it's his
colleagues it's his police family and
the wider emergency services that
you know he was dedicated to and proud
of and he served alongside
and so i know that this is something he
would want me to be doing
um so i know he'd he'd um be
right there with me one way that you
wanted everyone to remember
andrew what would it be he was just
kind just so kind um
and giving and just light-hearted
you know he'd be there for anyone but he
didn't take himself
too seriously there was always a smile
um you know and that's why everyone
misses him so much
because he just brought so much laughter
to all of our lives
but many things yeah